en direct de saint malo le dessinateur
ou groupe rap
bonsoir et puis agen racing ce soir en
finale du championnat de france de rugby
à un peu moins d'une heure du coup
d'envoi andrée marthe en direct du parc
des princes alors qu'elle le match ce
soir
rugby caviar ou soupe à la grimace andré
marcon parc des princes
alors on a des images pour l'instant
daniel herrero l'entraîneur de toulon
dans la tribune une caméra qui bouge
beaucoup
est-ce que nous avons la liaison avec le
parc des princes et andré marc on n'a
pas la liaison pour l'instant nouvelle
travers je prendrai ma je vous entends
alors qu'elle lâche ce soir rugby
carrière ou soupe à la grimace au parc
des princes
écoutez on espère surtout du beau jeu ce
soit entre le racé le sca jeûner et pour
cela je crois que j'ai deux invités qui
sont fort célèbre puisque c'est l'ancien
capitaine de l'équipe du racing qui
s'appelle les gérald martinez tout le
monde le connaît le président du showbiz
d'ailleurs je voudrais qu'on fasse un
beau plan sur son noeud papillon
regarder le comme c'est beau gérald
martinez qui nous a fait l'amabilité
d'être parmi nous ce soir et ensuite un
grand malheureux physique bo philippe
bérot qui ne jouent pas dans cette
équipe agenaise depuis déjà de longs
mois et qui la mort dans l'âme ce soit
on va regarder ses camarades de gand
disputer cette finale puis libéraux se
doit faire très mal soit être très
difficile oui je crois que c'est c'est
très dur effectivement d'être d'être
blessé vous n'allez pas pouvoir
participer à une fête comme un combat
c'est le la avec avec toutes les
conditions idéales mais je crois qu'il
faut se sont petit coup se donner la
raison et je crois que moisson j'ai pas
le choix et je fais je fermais
maintenant on voit cette finale
également cadets qui voit l'équipe de
beezik même 3 0 face au stade toulousain
une belle finale entre parenthèses et
avant de donner la parole gérald
martinez alors le show biz ce soir je
sais que jean baptiste lafond nous a dit
qu'il allait offrir un noeud papillon au
président françois mitterrand c'est tout
ce qui va se passer dans la soirée
oui mais c'est quand même un petit peu
c'est que les gens qui ont envie de
faire rêver
tu peux
et de faire vivre un petit peu le rugby
béraud et là il doit être malheureuse je
le ressens comme ça moi je me suis
écarté un petit peu j'ai fini le rugby
parce que je l'évolué lui il doit être
là il est là il doit être vraiment
grosse peine je dois dire qu'aujourd'hui
ça doit faire la fête
ça doit être le plaisir de la joie de
vivre j'espère que les deux équipes vont
pour faire le maximum pour faire rêver
tout le monde merci ni andré merci andré
martin en direct du parc des princes
agen racing dont il résumait bien sûr à
22h50 dans soir 3 l'actualité
internationale dominée ce soir encore
par le gabon un calme relatif a régné
aujourd'hui après 72 heures d'émeutes
mais c'est bien l'ensemble du pays qui
est secoué aujourd'hui par un mouvement
d'opposition hostiles au président bongo
à port gentil la correspondance de notre
envoyé spécial
pierre babey les compagnies pétrolière
port gentil et les cadres et les
techniciens continuent de rejoindre
libreville et la production
d'hydrocarbures a été réduite au 6
minimum technique
je viens à l'instant de rencontrer les
passagers d'un transall de l'armée de
l'air française
tout serait l'un des scènes de pillage
de me mais il faut aussi d'avoir pas été
réellement inquiété et certains
militaires français avouent leur
surprise de voir les européens à quitter
aussi rapidement port gentil pour
l'instant l'armée gabonaise
regardez les fermes et surveillent les
points sensibles à port gentil
les français quant à eux assurent la
sécurité des accès et des pistes de
l'aéroport à libreville tout est calme
et 30 mon calme
mais à la tombée du jour faire un
quartier commence déjà à transiter
libreville kerbala environ 15 cents
ressortissants français ont déjà été
rapatriés ce soir du gabon les
témoignages recueillis il y à quelques
minutes à l'aéroport de roissy font
parfois et à de véritables scènes de
pillage à libreville et à port-gentil le
témoignage recueilli ce soir par
marie-odile panier quelle est la
situation là-bas tendu
c'est à dire une chaude très chaude et
apparemment ce n'est pas encore terminé
qu'est-ce qu'il se passe qu'est ce que
vous avez vu concrètement des voitures
pillé des magasins pillés et des
voitures incendiées des inscriptions des
gens avec des matchs est qui menace
qu'est ce que vous avez laissé sur place
comment vous ça vous pensé revenir là
bas vous avez laissé quelqu'un là-bas
mon mari en principe toi revenions
demain mais on n'est pas sûr en étant en
roumanie
la différence est l'ouverture du procès
dennis kucinich et ce coup âgé de 38 ans
le fils du dictateur dont le procès est
retransmis cette fois à la télévision a
choisi de plaider non coupable de
génocide en roumanie correspondance de
notre envoyé spécial jérôme cathala
mais son vrai prénom et nicolas est
comme son père pourtant refusé
d'endosser les habits de dictateurs
sanguinaires les départs le compte du
quator et dès l'ouverture de son procès
en s'aimant avoir donné l'ordre à la
police et à la securitate de tirer sur
la foule le 22 décembre
il explique qu'il n'avait que les
manifestants n'avaient pas d'armes ni
qu'on se défend seul
amaigri il bafouille mal à l'aise vécu
comme ils avaient droit
alors que la température avoisine les 30
degrés dans pour le pays
son parcours est celui d'un fils de
famille successivement responsable des
jeunesses communistes de la capitale
ministre de la jeunesse puis premier
secrétaire du pc roumain pour la région
de sibiu scipion son procès s'est ouvert
dans une indifférence presque totale car
même s'il utilisait son pouvoir pour
séduire comme il la vraie avec nadia
comaneci par exemple entre romain voit
surtout en lui un faible un velléitaire
que la mère elena a toujours terrorisée
après la confirmation des résultats et
les 85% du président liège coup la
roumanie n'est pas à l'abri aujourd'hui
d'une véritable explosion sociale la
classe politique unanime pour réclamer
l'économie de marché oublie de préciser
à la population ce que sera le prix à
payer pour cela
reportage en roumanie jérôme cathala
marque
l'iem gb l'entreprise de machines
lourdes et bucarest
avec ses quinze mille employés et les
sur la liste noire du gouvernement
une liste qui comporte 150 noms pour
chaque cas une seule question peut-on
sauver l'entreprise
ou faut-il la fermer car selon les
roumains leur pays est dans le même état
que le japon après la guerre mais
surtout les ouvriers travaillent encore
pour une entreprise d'état ne
comprennent pas que la future économie
de marché signifie inflation et chômage
nous avons des gens qui sont partis mans
affamés qui ne sont pas prêts à accepter
des sacrifices il y à un état social qui
n'est pas disons compatible avec un
changement brusque il y a des gens qui
rejettent le communisme mais ils veulent
préserver ça c'est tragique ils veulent
préserver les commodités d'un système
socialiste
écoutez ces ouvriers ils ont voté à 90 %
pour le front de salut national et
attend de tous de lui comme avant non
nous n'avons pas peur des réformes
nous avons bien botté
non je ne peux pas être au chômage j'ai
trois enfants et comment je ferais si
j'étais chaud main à mon avis les
entreprises ne doivent pas fermée on
doit nous donner ce qu'il faut pour
continuer à travailler
c'est nous qui leur apprenons que le
sort de leur entreprise est actuellement
entre les mains du gouvernement
immédiatement le directeur général
qu'ils ont pourtant élu en janvier
dernier est prise à partie il ya de
fortes chances qu'une partie des
ouvriers de cette usine soit licencié
mais ce seront ceux qui ne font pas leur
travail
ceux qui ne prennent pas leur tâche au
sérieux bref la victoire politique du
front de salut national s'est bâti en
partie sur une méprise comme tous les
partis le front c'est que seul le
passage à l'économie de marché pourra
sauver le pays
mais il s'est bien gardé jusqu'ici
d'évoquer le prix d'une telle
transformation et c'est bien sur ce
terrain que l'opposition maintenant va
tenter de reconquérir les esprits au
cours du 19 20 le 12 mai dernier à
monsieur claude lanzmann qui était notre
invitée avait évoqué la france de 1939
et une rencontre entre monsieur von
ribbentrop le ministre et le ministre
des affaires étrangères français georges
bonnet sur l'éventualité d'envoi de
juifs madagascar dans une mise au point
le fils de georges bonnet le député
alain bonnet nous précise les points
suivants
lors de l'entretien qui élu le 6
décembre 1938 et non en 1939 le ministre
français a exprimé au nom de la france
son indignation contre les persécutions
exercées à l'égard des juifs
deuxième point contrairement aux propos
de monsieur lansman le gouvernement
français n'a jamais envisagé d'envoyer
des israélites à madagascar
le premier référendum écologique
organisé en france près de cent
cinquante mille électeurs de montpellier
et de 16 communes limitrophes ont tu as
décidé aujourd'hui de l'emplacement de
la nouvelle décharge publique
commentaires de jean marc pitte le
référendum écologique n'a pas soulevé
l'enthousiasmé populaire dans la région
de montpellier
son initiateur georges frêche ne
s'attendait pas à un miracle ils
jugeaient par avance une participation
de 5 à 10% comme correcte les électeurs
convoqué devait choisir entre
l'incinération et le tri sélectif de
leurs ordures domestiques
mais il avait surtout à se prononcer sur
le choix du
mas dieu comme nouveau site de leur
décharge jusqu'à maintenant les déchets
de montpellier et des communes
environnantes sont déversés auto sur le
territoire de la tess mais depuis 89 7
communes refusent de rester la poubelle
de la région le député maire de
montpellier georges frêche propose alors
un nouveau site
le mas dieu la commune de montarnaud sur
laquelle ils se trouvent s'oppose tout
aussi violemment à ce projet selon le
résultat de la consultation le conseil
de district qui regroupe les 15 communes
de l'agglomération montpelliéraine
saisira le conseil d'état pour qu'ils y
mettent un avis le préfet tranchera
ensuite en suivant ou en s'opposant à la
voix populaire sociale absence ce matin
encore dans les kiosques du quotidien
l'union de reims le syndicat du livre
cgt qui s'oppose au plan de
modernisation du journal menace
maintenant d'étendre le conflit à
d'autres titres de la presse française à
tout près 12 jours de conflit à reims
les localier du quotidien continue
cependant à travailler pour être prêt au
cas où le titre parviendrait à
reparaître à reims reportage de yannick
a aussi rien de nouveau dans le conflit
entre direction et ouvriers du livre cgt
aujourd'hui chacun campe sur ses
positions pas de négociations non but
pendant que les syndicalistes distribuer
leurs tracts béatrice journaliste à la
rédaction locale de reims fort en
reportage mon sujet d'aujourd'hui une
remise de la médaille de la famille
française prise de contacts photos
interviews la routine du local y est
pourtant depuis mardi personne ne lit
les papiers de br risque depuis le début
de la semaine les 97 journaliste de
l'union travail dans le vide
de retour au journal béatrice va écrire
son papier mais elle ne sait pas quand
il sera publié
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas une pom
être avant dans une semaine
dans un mois toute façon là on essaye
dans la mesure du possible
chaque fois qu'on se déplace sur un
reportage ou même comprendre
l'initiative de toujours penser à une
parution qui ne puisse puisse attendre
quelques jours quelques semaines est le
plus frustrant c'est d'avoir des
informations qui doivent être élus
feront tout de suite et de ne pas
pouvoir les donner
par contre les nouvelles circulent très
vite au sein du journal grâce à
l'éphémère feuille d'information
continue édité chaque fois qu'il se
passe quelque chose
le besoin d'informer est toujours bien
vivant dans la rédaction dans l'attenté
d'une éventuelle publication le travail
continue ont fait la tournée des
commissariats et des casernes de
pompiers
même si l'activité est ralentie ou en
tout cas bien différente de la normale
on reste prêt au cas où le journal
reparaîtra demain les sports la formule
1 et le nouveau coude à coude senna
prost demain à monaco le brésilien a
signé aujourd'hui sa 45e pole position
il aura à ses côtés en première ligne la
ferrari du français alain prost donc est
juste derrière les deux hommes il y aura
la tyrrell d'un autre français jean
alesi ambiance à monaco aujourd'hui
jean-bernard vite elio la foule le
soleil et des moteurs qui hurlent c'est
la carte postale du week-end à monaco
ici le grand prix ce dernier en grande
partie durant les essais de maintenant
dans la course il sera tellement
difficile de doubler sur ce circuit en
ville que le vainqueur est forcément
parmi les six meilleurs temps réalisés
aujourd'hui une minute 21 une seconde
314 millièmes record absolu pour ayrton
senna le brésilien a survolé le tracé de
la principauté
pour lui on peut dire que moi
c'est vraiment le pied l'occasion
d'ailleurs de partir en première ligne
pour la 45e fois de sa carrière
m et de se montrer très content d'avoir
fait la pole on a vraiment bien
travaillé et j'ai la chance d'avoir eu
des détours clair clair aussi la
détermination de prost sa ferrari marche
bien même s'il explique avec le nouveau
moteur elle a perdu en vitesse de pointe
il n'empêche que la voiture rouge et
dans la même seconde que celle de senna
alain signe le deuxième temps et annonce
la couleur
j'en tire puis toute façon il est il est
aussi un petit peu plus rapide donc je
crois que les voitures ne sont pas loin
en qualifications avec certainement un
avantage pour la mclaren mais quand on a
une différence même d'une seconde au
tour en cas dit que la cour comment la
ferrari est mieux donc c'est vraiment
vraiment très optimiste je sais que
demain il en ira pas loin de position
c'est sûr aussi que demain on retrouvera
jean alesi l'avignonnais qui efface tout
le monde cette saison tant il a l'air à
l'aise en se mesurant avec les plus
grands à l'édition la tyrrell à moteur
ford qui réalise le 3ème temps après
avoir signé ce matin les meilleurs
chronos dans la séance des essais libres
à monaco pour sa première participation
dans un baquet de l'efs
allez-y ses claques carrément sur cette
piste et il le dit je suis bien
je m'éclate et avec mon équipe et mes
ingénieurs on arrive à faire un bon
travail ensemble
et puis bon je me régale à mais grâce à
ses côtés en deuxième ligne on
retrouvera la williams-renault de
ricardo patrese en troisième ligne la
mclaren de gerhardt burger et l'autre
williams est de ceux du belge thierry
boutsen mansell ne partira qu'en
quatrième ligne à noter que alboreto et
gruyère ont été éliminés deux poids et
deux mesures la coupe de france de
football c'est bien sûr le racing qui
sort de l'ombre pour atteindre la finale
après sa victoire sur marseille 3 buts à
2 hier soir
mais c'est aussi saint-etienne qui fait
payer à robert herbin les rêves enfui
d'un retour sur la scène européens la
coupe de france a donc deux visages
dominique champions en coupe de france
plus qu'ailleurs le bonheur des uns
cache presque toujours la détresse des
autres avec jb range de ceux qui ont en
partie sauvé leur saison tranche
forcément avec la déception de ceux qui
ont au contraire tout perdre cette
reprise de volée de cantona n'est rien
d'autre en fait qu'à un coup de pied de
l'âne qui renvoie un plus mal loti à ces
problèmes et prépare une fois la fièvre
retombée une remise en question lourde
de menaces
je suis infiniment des cif et chacun
sait qu'en france un président déçu
c'est un entraîneur qui part moi j'étais
surpris je ne m'y attendais pas pour
tout vous dire
lui non plus le fonds ne s'y attendait
pas et son visage hier soir trahissait
une émotion bien légitime
et des gens qui fait peur
philippe piette a le bonheur revanchard
le voilà pourtant payé de bien des
tourments car hier soir son équipe a
trouvé une âme contre la morosité de la
conférence de presse de l'après midi et
le bonheur intense d'une femme match
historique
c'est toute la magie de la coupe qui est
passée par là et c'est de très loin son
meilleur profil
basket la deuxième défaite de limoges
depuis le début du championnat en match
retour de la finale du championnat
limoges s'est incliné cet après midi à
antibes sur le score de 100 à 80 16
derniers minutes dernières secondes
dirais-je même de la rencontre que vous
vivez ici la victoire d'antibes cents à
96 qui va provoquer une belle entre les
deux équipes belle qui décidera du titre
du champion de france donc et qui se
jouera mardi soir dans la salle des
limougeauds qui auront donc l'avantagé
et les faveurs du pronostic cannes
sachez encore en cyclisme que laurent
fignon a abandonné cet après-midi dans
le tour d'italie souffrent trop de chute
mardi dernier souffrant trop donc de son
dos blessés dans un instant nous irons
en direct à saint malo où s'est ouvert
hier le premier festival international
du livre d'aventurés de voyage nous
rejoindrons nos invités le dessinateur
hugo pratt le scénariste et dessinateur
de corto maltese et puis là michel
lebris qui est l'organisateur de ce
festival met tout de suite
présentation de cette grande
manifestation philippe surcouf jacques
cartier du gué trouve à châteaubriant
ces messieurs de saint malo d'autres
encore ont apporté à combien le goût de
l'aventuré des voyages de la littérature
la cité corsaire a décidé d'accueillir
cette année d'étonnants voyageurs
rassemblés sous le signe de la bande
dessinée de la littérature et du cinéma
les aventures premier festival du genre
étonnants voyageurs 90 c'est le
rendez-vous de plus d'une centaine
d'auteurs dessinateurs et scénaristes
dont les héros font de spirou à corto
maltesse dont les aventures nous ont
fait passer à tous des heures agréables
devant un livre une bd ou dans une salle
de cinéma
trois jours durant tous ces auteurs sont
confrontés au public à l'occasion de
rencontres de débats d'expositions et de
séances de signatures c'est l'occasion
aussi pour les plus jeunes d'exprimer à
leur façon leur goût pour l'aventuré
certains d'entre eux seront ils un jour
d'étonnants voyageurs
michel lebris et hugo pratt donc invité
du 19/20 en direct à saint malo ils vont
apparaître dans l'instant sur ma gauche
voilà qui est fait michel le bris quelle
est la finalité de ce festival on devra
vous reprochez de de copier un petit peu
tout ce qui se fait ailleurs un nouveau
salon du livre un nouveau salon de la
bande dessinée
alors non je crois que c'est vraiment
une manifestation tout à fait original
c'est s'appelle high tone en voyageur
pour bien manifester qu'il s'agit pas
d'un festival de plus de deux
spécialistes traversée de l'amazonie en
patins à roulettes mais vraiment
d'écrivain et notre rêve c'était de
rassembler les écrivains du monde entier
ont manifesté cette idée de la
littérature un peu le rendez-vous des
des enfants de stevenson et de conrad
disant est ce qui explique donc la
présence à vos côtés d'hugo pratt
et surtout de son héros j'ai envie de
dire corto maltese c'est le le grand
invité de ce festival à saint malo vous
lui avait consacré une énorme exposition
à tout à fait une énorme exposition que
nous ont donné nos amis de la louvière
en belgique et je vois qu'il n'ya pas de
plus beau symbole d'abord de l'union de
la littérature et de la bande dessinée
que l'oeuvre de hugo pratt qui est lui
aussi je crois un enfant de stevenson
hugo pratt
vous pouvez répondre à michel lebris
bonsoir mon fort évidemment je suis
comme beaucoup de nous et vous aussi
fils d'helen de l'imagination et de la
poésie des robes louis stevenson
alors moi et j'étais content de me
trouver ici et saint malo
mais alors votre héros et est très
littéraire parce que l'on sait aventure
ils côtoient des personnages célèbres
que ce soit jack london ou vous-même
hemingway ce sont de simples clin d'oeil
nous c'est beaucoup plus d'un regret que
je pense que c'est beaucoup plus que ça
c'est la ferc et corto maltese aussi il
a eu peut-être
des études classiques quand elle était
jeune alors ils se trouvent et bonne
compagnie avec des livres et des bonnets
de bons écrivains
alors comment vous situez-vous je sais
que la question vous a déjà été posée
mais comment vous situez-vous par
rapport aux autres dessinateurs de bande
dessinée vous avez vous des références
littéraires que les deux autres n'ont
pas peut-être non je ne veux pas parler
pour les autres parce que après tout je
viens de les rédiger tous des classiques
quel âge avait une certaine un
entraînement à la lecture pour les
autres moi je sais pas je crois que
beaucoup d autres dessinateurs il fait
la même démarche et il avril sas notre
point de vue et non les miens et votre
héros corto maltese c'est ce capitaine
sans navire vous allez puisés dans la
littérature encore ses prochaines
aventures dites-nous domo de l'avenir de
corto maltese l'avenir des comptes malte
échelle hebdo les bons très bien michel
lebris à un dernier mot il ya bien sûr
un certain nombre d'écrivains alvaro
mutis grand prix médicis étranger cette
année est présent également à saint malo
oui oui un verre au mutis et là est
d'ailleurs ravi de rencontrer hugo pratt
parce qu'ils trouvent des étranges
correspondance entre macro le gabier les
personnages de ses romans et corto
maltese une référence je crois
effectivement pour les deux seuls 2 de
stevenson
merci messieurs donc en direct du
premier festival international du livre
d'aventurés et de voyage étonnant
voyageur c'est son nom la bande dessinée
est en deuil aujourd'hui jacques lob
dessinateur et scénariste est décédé des
suites d'un cancer
il laisse l'empreinte de son humour
féroce dans de nombreuses publications
métal hurlant il a créé le personnage de
roger fringant il a également collaboré
avec alexis ce gotlib et soler au fameux
héros super dupont que vous apercevez
ici jacques lob était âgé de 58 ans il
avait obtenu en 1986 le grand prix de la
ville d'angoulême pour l'ensemble de son
oeuvre
la peinture soviétique à la mode à paris
pour finir ce journal un courant nouveau
amorcé en 1987 et qui draine aujourd'hui
des oeuvres en attendant tu parlais de
chefs-d'oeuvre des oeuvres venues de
moscou de leningrad ou deux
il ici les artistes sont encore inconnus
en europe mais leurs oeuvres s'arrachent
déjà reportage de nicole bappel et de
bernard brengues makoun ianine plusieurs
centaine de peintres soviétique dans les
galeries parisiennes véritable
déferlement l'art contenu retenu en urss
surgi en france si la pérestroïka
accorde le passeport au toit leurs rares
sont les peintres présents à paris nous
avons pu venir invité par une émission d
asile en france mais il a fallu trois
mois de formalité on ne peut pas rester
car le gouvernement soviétique change
trop peu d'argent et nous n'avons que
cinq tableaux et c'est le quota autorisé
quels sont les espoirs nous avons les
pieds sur terre nous avons que paris est
sensible aux grands artistes liés ici la
mémoire de grands peintres
nous ce que nous voulons que ce soit à
paris ou à moscou c'est vivre nouvelle
route de l'art pour les professionnels
français paris moscou où les lignes
grade profite pour eux mais pour les
peintres on peut se poser la question
les tailles et pour l'assurance pour
l'exposition pour le contrat mais le
peintre est tous à peu près 20 20 25%
expression symbole d'un climat politique
et social cette production est un
phénomène historique
mais dans ce vaste panorama il va
falloir trier le bon grain de l'ivraie
je ne suis pas certain qu'ils aient
collectionneurs et la meilleure
présentation des toiles qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui des toiles de la paire
historique 1 et puis pour les
investisseurs je me paraît assez
dangereux d'investir rue dans des toiles
qui sont actuellement
vraiment s'en suit sans suivi drouot
mercredi 100 toiles de 12 jeunes
peintres géorgiens étaient mises aux
enchères sous le marteau de maître
florence barron mise à prix cinq cents
admis francs pour des tableaux a dut gea
moins de 5000 francs donc l'engouement à
gérer avec prudence les codes actuels
des peintres soviétique ressemble fort à
des montagnes russes en avoir un instant
vous allez le voir il y aura du soleil à
la pochette de michel tour et je vous
retrouve à 22h45 pour soir 3 d'ici là
très bon début de soirée